i love the color orange but here's
something kind of weird about orange
if you write a word with orange letters
its letters
will not be reversed in a mirror
that was just a trick of course mirrors
reverse
orange letters except they
don't mirrors don't reverse anything
they send back exactly what lands on
their surfaces
this letter r appears reversed in a
mirror not because the
mirror has flipped it but because i have
in order to show the letter r to a
mirror
i have to flip the letter what i
see in the mirror is exactly what i see
in my hand
the trick works only because the letters
in the word choice have a very special
kind of symmetry
where when flipped to be shown to a
mirror
and then turned upside down they go back
to the way they originally looked